Fiona so let's see if this works guys I
just started the streaming five minutes
before the the times so I'm just gonna
have a nice uh a chat with you before we
start officially I am in beautiful
Krakow as you can see here I'm outside I
hope that uh you can hear me so let's
see if you can actually hear me which is
the most important thing I'm just going
to ask you here
can you guys hear me let's let's start
with this
you can hear it okay
yes
now I can I can hear myself on the iPad
so
I have to mute my iPad before I start
this is these are the technical
technical problems of going live uh hi
Mickey hi Eric hi Thomas Juan Byron okay
you can hear me clearly I'm wearing this
so I hope this works the only problem I
have is that I have an iPad just here
and if I speak I have to mute it but
apparently let me just check before I
give it a try I cannot mute it from here
I do not know why
but it doesn't matter because I can see
the chat here so I will avoid using my
iPad it's not the end of the world
so
um great to see you guys
um
give me another second
uh okay everything is fine we haven't
started officially yet so this is some
sort of Chit Chat
hi guys Mario
uh
uh Thomas asks me do you sometimes speak
in Argentina in an Argentinian version
of Spanish I do not I speak Spanish from
Spain
I have a few Argentinian friends but
I've never learned to speak Argentinian
Argentinian uh Spanish you know
anyway we still have five minutes to go
I see uh there's quite a few of you guys
coming it's always nice to talk to you
and to have a chat with you
um I kind of remember the last live
video I've made was maybe I'm not even
sure like six months ago a year ago I
don't remember I just checked it the
last the last one I remember or the last
one I checked uh was a year ago it was
like the 17th of July 2022 so time flies
[Music]
um
so what I'm going to do first of all
just a couple of things this is a q a in
English you can ask questions in other
languages I just have to translate it
into English when I when I when I say
them I'm just going to select as usual
questions uh from from the chat that I
see here
um and then you know we have 75 minutes
more or less so one hour and 15 minutes
foreign
so what I'm gonna do again I'm gonna see
look at the questions uh since I
obviously is as it is always the case
while I answer I see a deluge of other
questions I'll try to select uh the ones
that I deem cool appropriate uh
interesting uh Berta is going to
moderate the chat you can see uh she
she's very strict she just wrote chat
two Simple Rules she likes giving rules
so
um good sales Deutschland
and yeah I think we can actually start
still three minutes but I think
I think at this point might as well
start so first thing first first things
first
um I wanted to uh make an announcement
I'm gonna make an announcement now and
then I'm gonna say this again at the end
of the video I have this baby here as
you can see it's this is my Kindle and I
this is probably mirrored but this says
10 essential rules for smart language
learning so two days ago we actually
started and we launched the book this is
my first book ever it's a very special
package because it's both in a PDF and
ePub it's a digital product but it also
comes with an audiobook I've recorded
this in Rome
um so we have the you know you have the
book you have the audiobook and you also
have a series of interviews that come
with the book and
um officially we opened this we launched
the book two days ago the response has
been amazing hundreds of people that
bought the book and I've been
overwhelmed by love and all these
messages and people some people have
already finished the book and um
they're really excited I can see some
comments from students of the smart
language learning academy like Jamie
so this is very exciting for me
um and this is a new beginning this is a
breakthrough in my life because I've
been you know wanting to write a book
for a long time and many more will come
but this one is a little bit special
because it's not just about my methods
and I'm pretty sure you guys want to
know how I learn languages but I believe
that one of the most important crucial
aspects of language learning is your
mindset I think that emotions mindset
the way you see yourself the way you see
the world the way you see your potential
as a language learner really plays a
huge role and basically the book is a
story in my life is a story of my life
as a learner as a human being and how
I've evolved when I was like 12 for
example and I could not even speak
English I cannot even pronounce enough I
used to say inaug much to the to the
horror of my English teacher so I moved
from a very insecure or timid speaker
and learner to a confident person who
speaks 15 languages and and again the
the I think the core message of the book
is that anyone can do this and the most
important thing is your mindset first
and foremost because you can train for
methods there are so many people out
there that share methods to share
strategies but you cannot train for
mindset mindset is something that grows
on your growths with you when you have
when you test your limits when you get
out of your comfort zone and when you
realize we finally realize the potential
think about how how many limiting
beliefs we have you know like
hey can I uh can I actually learn this
language can I speak a language fluently
so there's a lot of questions that we
have a lot of doubts uh that even for
media Learners have am I ever going to
speak this language fluently and they
really make a difference
um the way you formulate the questions
and the way the your mindset really
plays a gigantic role so again this book
um is a labor of love it took a few
months took a long time with my
wonderful team we've put this together
and for those who want to get it there's
a promotion for four days it lasts until
tomorrow midnight and you can get it at
Half Price It's the entire package and
Berta has just shared the link with you
where if you want you can purchase the
book until tomorrow then we will have it
a normal price on the website
someone asked me here you're gonna have
it in Italian
uh if the book goes well first we're
going to put the English version on
Amazon so it's going to be paperback and
and then we're gonna translate it into
Italian and Spanish and I will read the
audiobook I will be very happy to read
both the other book in Italian and in
Spanish
so
um without further Ado let's go to the
questions here
so let me go up because we had some
interesting questions at the beginning
I'm trying to answer as many questions
as possible again starting from now we
have one hour and 50 minutes so uh let's
let's get started
uh so first of all let me turn off
what's up because I'm getting a lot of
messages right now
um encouragement Community Church this
is the very first question that that was
asked on the like top going from top to
bottom if you have an H2O level should
you watch uh movies with subtitles uh in
your mother tongue I would say yes if
you're first of all if you have if
you're upper Beginner I would not
recommend watching movies I would rather
listen to podcasts at that level and
then you build enough listening
comprehension enough skills to then
tackle movies movies news they're more
in the realm of let's say B2 when you
when you're more like a fluent speaker
even between B1 and B2 when you have an
A2 level I would say I would stick to
podcasts at that level or a little bit
higher uh even videos if you want for
example there's a serious easy language
is super easy languages they're perfect
for that until you get a good listening
comprehension and then you can move on
to movies to or to watch your movies and
you can watch them for example with
subtitles in your native language first
and then in your target language
nowadays you have things like language
reactor these are apps or actually
language reactor is a Google Chrome
extension that allows you to see the
movie in both we have double subtitles
strip you can see it both in your
program language in your native language
which is amazing so you have
comprehensible input at its best
let's move on to those a second question
vinishus asks could you please talk a
little bit about the use of the
bi-directional translation for each
language level beginner intermediate and
advanced do you keep a planet when you
reach an intermediate level this is an
excellent question uh vanishes
unfortunately I cannot delve into it
like in depth otherwise it would take
three hours to answer this question but
the let's say that the short answer is
no I use the bi-direction translation
the way I show it in the way I teach it
um in in at the Academy at the Smart
language learning academy just for uh
the beginner level because uh this allow
like the way it's built the domain aim
is actually not to remember stuff is to
get familiar with The Language by
translating back and forth and then at
the intermediate level and let's say I
don't use it anymore I just get I use
different techniques the the bottom line
is to get
um you know exposed to interesting
content and find a way to remember it
but at the intermediate level they do it
in a different way then I go back to
translation but I use I use a technique
that is called reverse translation that
is used at a very high level I've never
shown this I I've just uh trained my my
ex students when I was a language
approach with this technique and it's
going to be in the in the third course
in the third installment because we have
built a course for beginners the
bi-directional translation then we have
the overcoming the intrame plateau which
is for intermediate Learners and then
we'll build the um the ultimate
installment or the third installment of
the trilogy which is how to move from
fluent speaker to Native like speaker
and the reverse translation uh is a
technique that is going to be included
in that specific course
um and so the bottom line to answer your
question uh I use the bi-directional
translation only at a beginner level
then I um I don't use it anymore at the
intermediate level and then once I'm at
the advanced level I use a variation of
that is more advanced
so uh let's take a look at some
questions here
it is a pleasure to hear how accurate
Lucas polish is thank you Tom Thomas I
love I love Paul and I love spending
time here uh two days ago a guy told me
oh yeah I cannot tell your uh you're a
foreigner and that you know when when
someone says that to me I'm super
excited you know it's a big compliment
it's a testament to hours and and
decades I would say of work
so
um let me see here there's do you
sometimes speak in Argentina in
Argentinian version of Spanish in an
Argentina the Argentinian version of
Spanish I already answered this question
I was I started learning Spanish from
Spain and by accident never changed
so
um let me see
Juan asks what do you suggest to do in
case of directional translation I guess
that that stands for bft doesn't work so
well as in your case with Japanese well
I adapted so I I still use the technique
but with shorter pieces of content the
for example if you're trying to
translate a sentence that is too long
the technique falls apart a little bit
especially in Japanese and SVO sov
languages subject for object verb sov
like Japanese so I have to find a
different way around it or use a
different version of it because this I
think the principle still works but you
have to tweak things because languages
are a little bit different so every
language offers unique let's say
uh challenges so to speak
um good to go too hey Lucas how many
hours Luca my name is Luca and I live on
the second floor here it's the third hey
Lucas how many hours do you think I
should learn daily and to build up a
language core in a Slavic language
Ukrainian in six months and mainly
learned through reading through reading
a lot and through YouTube videos well
first of all the the answer is
what what is your native language
because if your native language is
another Slavic language that makes it
easier for you or if you have another
like other languages under your belt
There Are Slavic languages that
facilitates your task that's the first
thing but let's suppose that you're not
you your native language is not Islamic
language I would say that in that case
um in six months if you want to build a
language course you should learn for at
least at the very least one or two hours
there's always a problem that two hours
can be very taxing for a lot of people
so I would start by learning for an hour
and then maybe you can scale it up it
all boils down to what you want like if
you don't have to rush the country
because you have to work there
for other specific reasons that compel
you to learn fast then I would say that
I would start like I wouldn't worry too
much about that I would just worry about
um learning every day for at least the
first month and then you can scale up
this this is a secret start small and
then scale up with time
um then let's see here okay ready
already I read this question because I'm
going from top to bottom yeah
um so Mickey can you we organize our
thoughts
for can we speak more confident or how
can we leave the translator Mickey catch
asks I guess you you wanted to ask how
can you
get confident when speaking a foreign
language I would say that one of the
most important things I'm building as of
now by the way another course and I'm
very proud of this because this is kind
of coming out really well we ran a poll
within the academy and we wanted to know
what's the next course that you that you
would like to see almost everybody said
speaking so we're building that and
we're building a course on how to speak
more fluently and one of the core ideas
is that in order to speak more fluently
yes practice sure that's important but
confidence and your mindset is really
important and the way mindset impacts
your interaction with other people is
amazing so if you think about that we
have people focus a lot of people focus
on how can I get better how can I
improve the way my vocabulary my
pronunciation my syntax this is these
are all important components of what we
we call speaking skills but I believe
that communication skills are as just as
important as well as your confidence so
I think that in order to build
confidence one of the most important
things is to have experiences in the
language so don't think about fluency
just in terms of the words you know or
the amount towards you know that's an
important metric that's an important
measure of course and component but I do
believe that the experiences that you
have count counts you know so your
confidence grows when you're able to
interact meaningful meaningfully with
other native speakers or people who
speak the language your target language
uh in a meaningful way the more
experiences you have the better it gets
every time you learn a foreign language
every time that you have to experience
something uh like ordering something on
for example in the restaurant you're
scared Everybody's scared Allah nobody
nobody likes a bidding that but we human
beings as adults were scared of new
situary or something new so uh the way
the fastest way to build confidence is
to face your fears and I'm a little bit
scared you know and I I do it anyway I
still remember
when I was in Budapest there was this
grumpy lady you know Eastern style she
was very angry and I at the time 2017 uh
my friend Alessandra and I we had to go
to another town like not far from
Budapest and I told myself oh gosh I was
literally sweating and I was not
sweating because it was August I was
sweating because I would like I was
dreading the interaction which was
actually kind of difficult because I
asked her something in Hungarian knowing
that she didn't speak a word of English
she granted something and then we
managed to communicate but after that
you know after that Dreadful experience
my actually I thought if I can make it
here I can make it anywhere you know if
I if I manage to survive this situation
I can manage to survive anything and my
confidence grew and then I started
talking you know like interacting in
bars or in in restaurants and it all
made a difference so remember confidence
comes from
um practice but also experiences
so
um let me see here now I'm reading the
comments about exciting to read it way
to go a very cool
um I already said Anna there's going to
be an Italian version
uh let's see here
let me go down my listening in English
is very bad can you give me tips yes
it's it's the easiest tip is just to
listen to stuff that you can understand
as much as you can so this is the most
important thing when someone says I do
not understand it normally means you
haven't listened enough so you have to
listen as much as you can so now I'm
gonna go to the bottom and then up let's
see
um
[Music]
so someone says they're learning Swahili
this is one of the languages I'd like to
learn that would be very cool uh
the next one is going to be Turkish but
let's see
um
adnani asks I think I'm plateauing in
multiple languages now is your
intermediate Plateau program suitable to
be used in the situation or is it useful
to address only one language at a time
you can apply to any language the only
problem I see there is that maybe you're
you're you know you have a hard time
overcoming a plateau because you're
tackling too many languages this is a
common problem that you know we tend to
think the more languages I learn at the
same time the better but in the long in
the long run if you think about it it's
actually better to do one thing at a
time there's a famous book that is
called one thing the one thing you do it
applies to business but basically the
concept applies to language learning as
well we are
um we think there are so many languages
out there you're learning one but you're
missing out on all the others this fomo
thing like fear of missing out but the
reality is that my suggestion I would
actually suggest you can if you want you
can the course works really well for
everybody who took it there's all
students here who can tell you that
because they they are part of the
program but I wouldn't apply it to many
languages at the same time because uh
then you kind of disperse your energy I
would apply it to one language see if it
works then okay I've overcome the
intermediate the intermediate Plateau
through the course with this language
applying the method to this language
okay now let me try it let's try it out
on another language that's what I would
do
uh uh then let's see here how much do
you understand languages that you
haven't studied yet Slovak Bulgarian Etc
well this it happens that I had
conversations and languages I do not
speak but I for example last year I was
two years ago I was having a
conversation with the Slovak parents of
uh my ex roommate uh flatmate actually
and I was speaking polish they were
speaking Slovak
um slowly and we were understanding each
other perfectly so that that that was
great
will Luke ever learn Modern Standard
Arabic that's possible but I uh as of
now I want to learn Turkish and then
we'll see
um
So Daniel says I try to buy your ebook
with my Visa card last night and I
couldn't try several times we you can
send me a message we can figure that out
later there's a lot of you know people
ask me how can I buy the book by through
PayPal so I addressed this one by one if
you send me a message we'll figure that
out do not worry
um have you read Atomic habit yes and I
I would also suggest
um tiny habits by BJ Fogg so Atomic
habits is great I have it in three or
four languages I bought it in Polish
recently and I would highly recommend it
and yes I have integrated that into
language learning and into my life that
and a tiny habits
um and it really makes a difference and
this is what I teach also at the Academy
it's not just language learning but it's
the entire integration of habits uh you
know productivity hacks and language
learning all combined
uh does Mandarin help impede you from
learning Japanese there's two completely
different languages I
I don't think so I think that Japanese
and Korean I would confuse them at the
beginning if I learn them at the same
time or if I learned one and then five
years later I would I learned the the
next one I think that would help but
Chinese and Japanese like
in terms of uh pronunciation they're
completely different so no they haven't
interfered at all
so let me go up here Luca you're the
best thank you so much do you think the
shadowing technique and the shadowing
technique can it be useful to improve
fluency in language and what do you
think about using bilingual books to
acquire vocabulary at an advanced level
um okay two interesting questions I
think the shadowing is if I don't know
if it's gonna help you with fluency but
it's it can help you with articulation
so articulation is a part of
pronunciation it can help you if you
know how to Shadow correctly and you
know how to apply the technique
correctly I think it can help you with
articulation which is part of
pronunciation and as far as fluency is
concerned maybe indirectly but I think
that when it comes to developing a skill
you have to practice that skill directly
and the best and fastest way to improve
your fluency is just to speak the
language that's what I would do so I
would say uh shadowing is great for
pronunciation articulation it's an
exercise you can do five minutes a day
or ten minutes a day but then practice
speaking because that's what really is
going to move the needle so to speak
um then let's go up what do you think
about Norwegian I think it's a wonderful
language very similar to Swedish and
danish I speak Swedish fluently Danish a
little bit less but a region I loved it
but I don't think I'll ever learn it not
because it's uninteresting but it's very
similar to length to to a language or
the like two languages I already know
and there's so many languages out there
that you know there's not enough time
um
so why do you why do you think there are
so many language learning methods
available in new apps or being created
all the time why do I think that
um I don't know if that's what you
wanted to ask Mamadou uh yes there's a
lot of learning methods but you know as
someone said very wise men said some I
don't remember 200 years ago principles
are more important methods yes there are
methods but I think that the most
important thing is to figure out what
are what are the underlying principles
that govern
um efficient second language acquisition
that is what counts once you understand
the underlying principle principles of
the process then you can leverage those
principles to create your own language
learning recipe that's what counts you
know Jordan what methods can I use to
get to a C2 level in my target language
I'm building an another that's the as I
said before another course that's a
complex there's a very complex question
Jordan but just to uh
you know and very briefly I would say
that
the way to get up there to the upper
echelons of language learning is to
constantly get out of your comfort zone
and do things that are slightly more
difficult and challenging uh than your
current level that is what is going to
help you improve because uh there's some
a little something called return of
investment the more skilled you are with
the language the more effort you have to
make in order to improve so that's the
reason why at the beginning it all seems
like oh I'm making a lot of progress but
then then you stall for whatever reason
you plateau you get into this plateau
and you have the impression that you're
not learning you are but much more
slowly so this gets people into like
people get desperate they say oh I
stopped learning it's not true but
you're learning much more slowly
so
um
cow Cal Finnegan I'm currently learning
Greek my beloved Greek wonderful
language I'm using acino via French but
I need to know I need to find more
content to learn passively do you have
any recommendations yes I do Greek is
one of my favorite languages I love it
um today I had a very nice lesson uh
with uh my tutor with a Greek tutor and
uh it's Greek is going great I wanted to
tell you something about this I wanted
to make a video about this and I'll
share this in a second anyway to go back
to going back to what uh to the question
um cal
um for Greek I would definitely get easy
Greek I am pretty sure you know and
their podcasts now if you don't have an
A2 language there's something called
American let me let me let me try to
find an American
University Greek podcast that's what I
use
learn Greek podcasts from the Atlantic
from the Atlantic America American Union
yeah I found it here
uh I don't know if this is still uh
working though I'm not 100 sure but
there it is
I just um shared it with you uh you
should find all pot like an entire
series of podcasts for free or if you
can't find those if there's not
available anymore I would use uh pod 101
Greek pot101 that's uh that's a very
good resource you can use you can have
you can you can do the whole package
this is what I did I finished assimil I
used pod 101 and then I moved to I moved
down to the easy Greek stuff that is
absolutely wonderful I'm having a blast
listening to Greek every day I'm going
to Greece in a month so I'm super super
excited
um
let me go up here
let me see here
we got a discussion here between Berta
and someone else about Chinese
um what is what is your opinion about
tools like chat GPT to learn a language
um I think it's going to facilitate some
things I've I've been using it a little
bit but I stick to the simple rule that
listening and reading reading and
listening to stuff I like is what is
going to make a difference the the
problem with chat GPT is that there's no
audio I recently found out that you can
actually and I installed a Chrome
extension where you can have chat gbd
talk to you so there's like they they
literally let me see if I can find it
here it's called I can see the icon but
for whatever reason uh it doesn't it's
not telling me the name but if you type
something like Google Chrome extension
voice chat GPT you will find it again
it's robotic I prefer authentic content
like people talking about interesting
stuff or people having conversations or
real authentic content that you can
listen to that is we're really going to
make a difference we've got to make a
dent well make a difference in your
language learning that is what is going
to move the needle you can use cat GPT
as a nice tool to integrate you know
your language learning session but I
wouldn't let that let's say distract you
from the main activity or the main
activities language
language is a complex skill that is can
be learned in a simple ways just that we
make it much more complicated than it is
than it is
um actually listening and reading
reading and listening and then just
either reading or listening once you
have the capacity of you know either
listening or reading to authentic
content interesting enjoyable and
understandable comprehensible is at the
core of efficient of an efficient
language learning routine or strategy
chat GPT is nice you can do some grammar
drills you can do maybe I don't know
Anki or whatever it is but that should
be on top of this core so you should
spend at the very least 30 minutes if
you have time on like listening to stuff
you can understand that you like reading
maybe at the same time maybe if you have
five minutes you can use chat GPT
depending on how much time you can
invest in into language this is what
this is a you know profound truth that
I've figured out just recently and it
has completely revolutionized my
language learning because before well
maybe not revolutionized but it really
made it Skyrocket because before I
thought ah it's counterintuitive you
know what's a lot you have to read and
listen to stuff all the time but what
about speaking what about using a
language what about interacting with
people what about using chat GPT it's
all fine and dandy but I believe again
that reading and listening to stuff is
has never been easier than now
we live in an amazing area where we can
find all sorts of things that we like we
can we can select our own resources and
we can spend the whole day potentially
theoretically listening to stuff we love
so
um
let's see uh Luca how is your Danish uh
going my Danish is not going because I
stopped learning it if I got to tell you
the truth I wanted to make a video about
that because I I think when it comes to
learning or maintaining multiple
languages at the same time you have to
make choices that right now my love is
I'm courting so to speak Greek Hungarian
and and most of all Serbian so there's a
lot of amazing things happening I just
uh started you know speaking Serbian
also sending messages on WhatsApp
and I'm learning it fast and uh and
these are the three languages I'm
focusing on then I think okay Danish
what about Japanese what about Chinese
what about so there's other languages
that I cannot I I don't have the time
nor the energy to tackle it's just you
know thinking of
trying to learn or maintain 15 languages
every day is absolutely not realistic
not feasible I would go crazy if I did
you know if you if you do the math we
have 24 hours I have to sleep at least
seven or eight hours then we have 16
hours then what it's been 30 minutes or
15 minutes for every language
it's not my style I prefer using the
languages anyway well I the whole the
entire goal of language learning for me
is to have a better life so it's not
just it's not just an intellectual
Pursuit so when I speak language as well
that's the moment where I uh I get
excited that's the moment where I talk
to people and I have a cool experiences
and all that that's what makes a
difference and and fortunately or
unfortunately I can do that in 10
languages but five others well there are
the the proverbial so-called uh back
burner and that's fine
so uh let me see here
uh would you ever like to learn Romanian
yes
um I in the book I talk about that I
start with Romanian the entire book
starts with uh why I failed well maybe
it's not failed but why I stopped
learning Romanian after
um after starting it back in the day I
don't even remember was 12 years ago and
I would like to go back I would like to
visit Romania there's a lot of Romanians
in Italy they're lovely people
and a lot of my fellow and polygon
friends speak Romanian so they make me
jealous like I'm gonna see them on the
polygon Gathering or other events
speaking Romanian so well and I tell
myself I want to speak for a minute as
well so this is gonna this is bound to
happen sooner or later
uh Nikolai asks what do you think about
your recent visit in Poland the polygon
Gathering was good so first of all I'm
in Krakow so I'm in Poland I'm going to
stay here until the beginning of
September before flying to Greece I love
everything Krakow everything Poland uh
in the summer because
in winter it's a little bit Shadow is
there right
so it's just a little bit you know the
polls say all the time oh my God it's so
gray here in in Winter and cold I like
spending two three three months here
um and Croco especially in krakows just
my favorite city in Europe and the
polygon gather was great every time I
come here I just have a blast so to
answer your question I'm having a great
great time as usual
um
so let's see here what do you think
about language learning languages with
music I think that
Costanza asked me this question I think
that's great I think that that should be
on top of what I said before the core
should be listening uh to stuff
listening and reading to let's say
reading and listening to stuff you like
like conversations and podcasts or short
stories stuff that contain language in
your everyday life then if on top of
that you also like the music of you know
if you if you want to listen to music
all the more power to you you know
that's another activity that you can uh
that you can engage in that is going to
allow you to get exposure to the
language any activity that uh where you
were getting exposure to the language
authentic language is great but it
should come in my book on top of these
other activities you can I don't think
you can actually learn a language just
by listening to music I know that this
is not what you're doing but if I have
to choose language is always about okay
what do I do today I have an hour I
don't want to spend my time with in a
meaningful way that makes makes me move
the needle so to speak I I wouldn't do
that I would spend time as I did today
to give an example
first thing in the morning I was
listening to a podcast in Greek easy
Greek I love I love these guys so you
have a real language between two people
speaking you have
um this is this is what moves the needle
you understand how people talk to each
other music maybe you can do it while
you're running you're listening to
um I don't know the music spoken you
know the the singer singing in that
language that's fine but it's something
on top
so
um
and let me see here uh there's still
some questions from Berta going back and
forth you can't read Chinese out loud
hey look I've been learning like two
languages but recently got a job in a
new country uh let me see here because
it's changing very fast
I have to scroll up and down what should
I do to not lose momentum when the two
I'm already learning I've been learning
to let me let me reread this again
Anonymous user user I've been learning
two languages recently got a job and a
new country where I quickly have to
learn the language what should I do to
not lose momentum with the two I'm
already learning well you have to make a
choice you have to tell yourself how
many how much time do you have per day
and if you have say two hours then great
you can spend maybe 30 minutes with one
language 30 minutes with the the other
language so the two languages you're
learning and maybe the third one you can
spend the bulk of the time
trying to tackle the third one because
it's a new one but then it depends on
how much time and energy you have now
you have to move to another country get
you got to other fish to fry so to speak
so either you know you drop one for a
little bit for three months and you just
exclusively focus on the language that
you have to learn and then you go back
to the the one or the two languages
you're learning there's a there's a lot
of options it really depends on you if
you don't like dropping languages but
you're strapped for time and for energy
I would say you know maybe you you can
learn both languages 15 minutes 15
minutes and then the rest of the time I
would I would dedicate it to the
language that you need to learn because
you have to go
to you have to you have to go abroad
uh let me see here oops now
went down
so
can you tell us about taking breaks in
language learning that's an excellent
question I like like athletes you know I
really recently read this book I don't
remember the title to tell you the truth
but I think that athletes especially top
performers they alternate intense
periods of activity and um you know then
they take a rest I think the language
learning I
you know I'm an advocate for learning
every day but I've I've come to realize
the power of actually taking a break
because no matter what the brain gets
momentum so even if you take for example
we organize these uh three month
challenges and once they finish we have
a month uh Hiatus you say Hiatus I'm not
sure
um you know a month a 30-day break the
students are really uh sad because they
want to continue some just create their
own worksheets and now we have a
notebook challenge which is uh which our
student Diana created so that's that's
fun in August
um but I believe that for example I've
been learning Serbia the entire year and
I thought okay well you know these
challenges are really
um intense and
um we started the first one in January
until uh the beginning of April I was
actually glad that I took a break for a
month even if it might be sound crazy to
the look of like two years ago or four
years three years ago I might have felt
guilty and a lot of students shared this
sense of oh I feel guilty for not for
not doing Greek or German or French
whatever but I think that if you take
breaks like short breaks two three four
uh days or even a week
um especially when you go traveling or
you have other things to do or there's a
very intense period in your life for
whatever reason I think that's totally
fine as I said before ideas the brain
never stops learning so you give it food
and the there's a slow digestion
sometimes we stop learning for a while
and we go back to the language we even
better than before and we ask ourselves
why stop learning well you didn't stop
learning you think you stopped learning
but your brain never stops learning your
brain records everything your brain
never forgets you give it the right food
and the brain is going to do its strict
and it's going to do it well
so
um
there's still something going on between
Adam and Beth I hear about Chinese I
cannot follow that conversation
unfortunately when good to go to when
should one start to learn grammar more
deeply I'm advanced in French I can
speak about pretty much everything and
understand the content that I like is is
it now time to learn grammar
um I would say rap you have to learn
grammar all the time it's not whether
you have to learn grammar or not it's
how you learn it from the from the
get-go from the beginning you start
learning grammar in my book just by
using comprehensible resources where you
get to get exposed to interesting
dialogues and then you have some grammar
notes that facilitate the understanding
the comprehension of this content right
uh but I never
I never opened a grammar book or a bit
better I did when I was at school and I
dreaded every moment of it when I
started learning Russian I still
remember I still have this this book
this gigantic book right and I open it I
saw these cases and all these exercises
and I said oh my God just looking at it
right uh makes me dizzy and that's not
how you learn a language you can maybe
for a scholar who wants to understand
the intricacies and quirks of the of the
Russian grammar that's fine but that's
not to learn a language you learn a
language by getting exposure to
comprehensible interesting content
comprehensible means something that you
can understand either because you have
the translation or because you have on
top of that grammar notes that that
explain or help you understand uh the
these grammar points in in your case I
what I would do good to go is I would
write dissertations short texts and get
Corrections live you know maybe even
indirect Corrections that's one of the
best ways to improve your grammar is by
practicing or giving speeches and
getting corrected It's You Learn by
deduction rather than deliberate
learning of grammar you can get into
grammar like you can open a grammar book
and try to learn but that's not a very
good efficient way of learning grammar
you learn to perfect your skill your
eloquence and the way you
uh you speak when it comes to grammar by
getting feedback by getting out of your
comfort zone and getting feedback let me
give you for example Let me Give an
example so we can prepare a speech there
should be structures you have maybe
three points then you can just talk you
record your voice you get
um you should hire someone or you should
have someone who can provide good
feedback on how to improve the way you
express yourself I think that's the you
know it's a little bit complex but I
think
um it's one of the best ways for me most
direct ways to improve the way you you
talk because grammar at the end of the
day is how elegantly concisely we can
express our thoughts
so uh let me see here
Maya Maya hello from Poland hello from
back from Poland from karakov I'm going
to Teddy for tomorrow I was in Tenerife
a few months ago absolutely gorgeous I'm
I'm in the half of the Spanish Asimo so
you're halfway I guess you might you
meant that Spanish Arsenal book and I
have Basics what do you recommend to
prepare yourself with ordering food and
talking to people
um
you can prepare some questions or you
can prepare some answers but at the end
of the day I think the most important
thing is just to relax and yeah prepare
a couple of lines but be ready to feel a
little bit awkward if you don't
understand something you know if you
order something and then someone blurt
something the problem is more in
understanding rather than speaking
because you can always read something
that you prepared or just show it to the
waiter just to give an example but
understanding is a different matter we
tend to think that in the interaction
with with a waiter for example is
something relatively simple but it's not
because the you know you ask something
and then the guy goes right and you go
like oh I didn't understand and then in
that moment you tell yourself what do I
do do I tell them I don't understand I'm
gonna look foolish oh gosh and all this
stuff so prepare for the unexpected and
the awkward but if you're ready to
embrace that you're going to have a
blast so yes you can prepare questions
but when you have an A2 you're going to
find a little bit difficult to interact
anyway I don't want to sound
discouraging but you should actually
especially because it's discouraging or
can be awkward you should give it a try
and when you actually
manage to communicate you know even
towards alike if in Tarzan like language
that's great that's a victory that's
that adds a little bit to uh to your
experience of of learning the language
of using the language of of interacting
with people in a meaningful way
let me go down here
um let me see there's a lot of
interesting questions what's your
opinion about assimil Mario Milano asks
is that a good is that a good tool to
start with
I guess you're Italian so with me uh I
would say yes Asimo is one of the best
tools uh in my in my book speak in a
books the best resources you can find
when it comes to uh starting any
language from scratch
so yes I would say it depends on it
depends on the language for Asian
languages it's not that great
unfortunately but for European languages
I think you should give it a try
so let me see here I look at from
Ecuador hi back from praco Poland
um so
let me see how do you keep myself from
hesitating in a foreign language I have
a C1 level in English however when I
speak I find myself hesitating more than
I would like to this is a lesson I
wanted to share and
um
I I shared it with my
um whether people subscribed to the
newsletter so I've never really shared
it here I think on YouTube but
um I had recently uh where I tried to
record a conversation with CZ CZ is a
YouTube fellow YouTuber and she makes
um Hungarian you know Hungarian content
or let's say content for Hungarian
Learners and then
um we record this conversation in
Hungarian and I was sweating and I was
just like my mind was constantly going
blank and I was like what am I doing
this what this sounds awful and she I
think she understood that too that I was
I was not able to
um you know I was having a hard time
speaking Hungarian but then a few months
later I was in Budapest and with my my
teacher Petra with whom I have normal
conversations I was speaking of the cuff
no problem talking about everything
without any major major problem or
hesitation I believe that the reason why
this happened because my language skills
were similar both with CZ and it didn't
change in a matter of months with CZ and
and Petra but I think that the mindset
with which I approached a conversation
or any conversation in general makes a
real difference think about that if you
are hesitating it's probably because you
think you're performing you have to
impress someone you're in this in
performance mode I have to impress I
have to get a good Mark I have to people
have to be in awe of my skills or I have
to prove that I'm good this I you know
it's very complex to explain what
happens in the brain but basically this
gets in the way so your prefrontal
cortex with which you're trying to you
don't speak and your emotional system
the limbic system they're finding with
one another that's why you're hesitating
because your mind is tackling too many
things at the same time be water my
friend you know someone would have said
I think it's Bruce Lee be water means
focus on just communicating and if you
focus on that you will see if you start
getting into that kind of mindset you
will actually see that you're able to
say much more than you think and without
hesitating but it takes a little bit of
practice and you have to get into that
mindset you're hesitating not because of
your skills or not necessarily because
of your skills but more because of your
mindset of course if you're hesitating
because you don't know words or you
don't know Expressions that's one thing
but if you're at C1 I I don't think it's
a problem with vocabulary I don't think
it's a problem with grammar I think it's
more a problem of mindset the mindset
with which you
um approach a conversation I don't know
if you guys can write it on the chat I
don't know if this ever happened have
you ever hesitated have you ever felt
stupid have you ever approached a
conversation with the will of impressing
someone or of Performing or getting a
mark you know getting a good Mark so uh
this is a very important question or a
set of questions that you have to ask
yourself when I speak how do I feel do I
want to impress or do I want to express
that's the difference if you want to
impress oh okay that's fine but if you
want to express it's gonna get it's
gonna be a different new level think
about that not impress Express express
your thoughts express your emotions talk
about interesting stories share your
life share your hobbies talk to people
for the sake of meaningful conversation
not for getting a good grade not
forgetting praise but to actually talk
and communicate with people that is what
makes a difference that is what should
drive you to learn any foreign language
because at the end of the day speaking a
foreign language makes you connect with
the world and that is how it should be
do you use Wikipedia to read about
specific topics yes but I don't do it so
much for us when it comes to language
learning I don't do it so much to
improve my languages I on and off I
watch a movie and then I like you know
reading the plot maybe if I if I watch a
movie in Polish I'll read the the plot
in Polish or in whatever language but
normally I do it in English or any time
but it's more like for the sake of you
know of reading something interesting
I'm thinking about learning languages
there all again to Wikipedia to learn
languages
uh do you use the bi-direction
translation method for learning Mandarin
Jean Paul asks yes yes sir I I did and
it worked like a charm especially for
Chinese Japanese a little bit different
but for Chinese it was wonderful both
for learning how to type in Chinese and
for tones and and for learning the the
structure of the language but truth be
told Mandarin Chinese is much easier in
terms of grammar and structure and
syntax than Japanese which is a
different ball game
uh let me see here
um El informador I'm a Spanish speaker I
want to learn to speak Chinese how do I
learn Chinese characters well speaking
in Chinese characters
they're kind of you know you can speak
Chinese without learning Chinese
characters my my recommendations I was
saying before is you could use it by
director and translation but if you
don't know what the bi-directional
translation is or if you don't know
about the course I have it doesn't
matter my my suggestion would be just to
type sentences in Chinese first of all
get a book that contains dialogues right
Asimo is decent for uh Mandarin Chinese
not the best but decent but get a foot
to get a a grasp um to get a let's say a
solid foundation in the language and
then you for example can download
pinging you can download the the
keyboard and you can use ping Ying I
would not recommend learning how to
handwrite if you want to that's fine I
wouldn't recommend that it's gonna it's
a skill on its own it's gonna take hours
and hours if you want to speak Chinese I
think you should aim at learning how to
type recognize characters and you can do
that by downloading for example a
keyboard and start typing it's fun it's
not not even that difficult because for
example let's say
you just type
literally and then the
the the software program just transforms
it into
um
characters so you learn to type you can
say it out loud when you type it so your
your brain is going to associate the
sound
tone with the transliteration and with
the Ping Ying
now to explain the details uh it's going
to take a long time so we don't have
time to do that but think about that in
order to speak you have to learn you
have to get exposed to dialogues and you
have to understand these dialogues and I
would definitely get askimil and I would
avoid handwriting because it's going to
stop you dead in your tracks from the
get-go if you try that route but you're
you can do whatever you want
oh
Carlos what do you think about the user
mnemonics such as the Memory Palace and
language is very interesting question I
am going through a course I'm pretty
sure the some of you guys know Jim quick
he's pretty famous so I'm doing one of
his courses for uh you know Memory
Palace and uh
the locky methods I think it's in any
time would be launchy that comes from
Latin lokai method Lockheed I'm not sure
how you say it in American English uh
but regardless of that I believe that
you know when people say oh in order to
remember words you have to associate
with something or with a sound or
I am not sure that these uh
mnemonic techniques actually work
because language learning is a dynamic
skill that involves uh something that is
called procedural memory apart from
deliberate memory in your brain so
language learning is not just about
learning words it's all the breaks that
make up the language it's also about
associating these words to form
sentences is much more complex than just
remembering lists of words mnemonics
work uh you know these techniques work
very well for memorizing certain things
statically but I have never heard of a
memory master who used these techniques
in order to speed up the process of
language learning maybe I'm wrong but
that's not I've never used these
techniques these techniques are
interesting to train your memory to keep
your memory you know sharp so to speak
and I'm enjoying every moment of the
course I'm taking but to tell you the
truth is more like for the fun of it but
for language learning I don't I don't
see
honestly how useful that can be but I
might be wrong if there's someone here
who tried these techniques and is speaks
languages like a pro well come to the
four and let's talk about it
it's learning Dutch a way to learn
Deutsche interesting question
well if you know a language like German
it will help you learn Dutch if you
learn Dutch you will help you learn
German because they're similar but only
if you have learned one and well enough
and you speak it fluently in that case
it's an advantage if you haven't formed
a course so to speak so you have a like
an A2 level you're a beginner level at
say German and then you start Dutch good
luck with that because you're going to
confuse the two like in two languages do
not learn two similar languages at the
same time uh that's my uh recommendation
that's something I I would avoid but
then everybody can do whatever they want
um okay so let me see here
uh
uh in your live stream is Stefano he
told you Anki is necessary for his
Georgian and Japanese because oh I lost
that question I don't know where it went
so let me see where he has Georgian in
Japanese because of the script do you
really think it's necessary or can this
be worked around I I don't remember
having I don't recall having a
conversation with Stefano talking about
Anki being necessary for his children in
Japanese maybe uh but I don't think his
Anki is necessary to learn any language
but if again if you like using Anki well
that's great
um I don't think that even for languages
such as Georgia and Japanese it's like
it's necessary to me uh getting exposed
to interesting content is what really
counts interesting comprehensible
content for a long period of time every
day possibly for 30 to 60 even 90
minutes that will do the trick if on top
of that you like using Anki why not but
you know it's up to you I've never used
it well I've recently to make a video I
tested it for a little bit
but it was not my cup of cake can you
say that couple cake not sure a cup of
tea actually
anyway so
um
let me see uh Juan hi Luke a big fan of
your channel what's the best approach to
action reduction in English the best
best approach to action reduction is
accent Foundation that means that when
if you've been speaking a language for
quite a long time then trying to reduce
your accent good luck with that because
it's like a knot you know just like
we're good at learning we're very good
we're not very good at unlearning so you
have to undo everything you've done all
the patterns or the language patterns
and that's very tough to do so uh
I for everybody who asked me can I
reduce my accent I always tell them you
can but it's a lot of work if you're an
actor you have to work in Hollywood like
I think I think that's a French actress
who didn't speak English that well now
she speaks her really well she had her
coach she had a lot of money to spare
and to spend
um then yes but I would say
um if you want to speak a language well
I think you should pay attention to its
problems you should be interested in in
implementation from the get-go so if
you've been speaking any language for
five years or 10 years or 70 years
whatever and you have a very thick
accent
is is going to be extremely difficult uh
to change that accent I have I had in
the past as a Language Coach but also as
an accent coach people came to me and
said hey can I can I speak like a native
I I still remember to this day an Indian
guy he had been living in the U.S he had
a very sick accent and there was we
tried a few things but I already told
him from the get-go this is not going to
change but he insisted he wanted to do
the training but it's really it's really
difficult unfortunately to reduce your
accent
um
I I believe everybody's good everybody
is potentially good
um potentially we can learn to speak any
language really well maybe not get a
native-like accent but close but it's a
matter of paying attention of interest
in a number of other factors and
rare are the individuals who actually
pull that off I don't think it's even
that
[Music]
um
that interesting uh well that that well
it's interesting of course it's not even
that important of a goal the important
that the most important thing is just to
to be understood and have a very clear
pronunciation that's important native
like it's more difficult
oh let's see
Andrew Hungarian has a fearsome
reputation but for a native English
speaker is it that much harder than a
slav language I always talk about this
with Petra who's my uh you know the
Hungarian teacher I talked to before
it's just different Hungarian is not
necessarily uh a difficult language it's
very diff it's very different so it
takes time to adapt to the system but
there's a lot of actually refreshingly
easy features or simple features or
let's say features that you can learn uh
much faster than other languages so
it really depends I don't think we as a
native English speaker can compare
Hungarian Slavic languages every every
language has its difficulties and I've
heard and met people learn Hungarian
very fast
by the way I'm gonna make a YouTube
video interviewing a guy who learned
this language amazingly fast and he had
a he's a cool very cool guy
Tomah
and some other people learned Slavic
languages really well really fast or
faster than Nigerian so I would just say
if you're interested in the language and
if you do the right things and if you
learn for two three four years and you
got a chance of using the language in a
meaningful way it doesn't matter what
it's more important it's more difficult
than Russian or Slavic languages that's
yeah if you focus on on that language
and you really want to learn it no
language is impossible to learn if you
really
want to learn it and you want to use it
so
um
Reggie hey Luca my personal language
learning experience very much supports
the fact of listening and reading or key
to acquisition and the stuff about
mindset is fundamental for fluid speech
I I'm glad that you agree Reggie
um recalling vocabulary and speaking is
a big struggle for me any tips on how to
improve language output when there is no
one to speak with
um you can talk to yourself
um I think one of the best ways uh of
the the fastest coolest ways of actually
uh getting to speak without having to
talk to native speakers is talk to
yourself I do this all the time now I
cannot show you the notebook that are
inside because it's a little bit messy
but basically what I do is that when I
have conversations with my tutor but
even when I listen to a podcast for
example I jot down a couple of sentences
bits and pieces of language and then I
talk to myself try and explain uh you
know the content of the podcast to
someone and that works really well it's
called the explanation effect and this
you can apply it to anything it's one of
the most uh useful techniques when it
comes to reading and understanding what
you read you read something you try to
explain to your to explain the content
to your imaginary friends so it's not
just for language learning but when you
do it for the sake of improving your
foreign language that's even more
powerful because you're talking to
yourself you're using
um words in context and and you're
applying activating the explanation
effect that is what I would do it's not
that you're not good at recalling
vocabulary it's just a matter of
practice so here also the language you
use is really indicative of the kind of
mindset you're in might be oh I'm not
good at recalling words am I bad at it
no you're not bad it's just that you
know you have to work to find a way to
activate your vocabulary
and uh and recalling speaking is a is a
constant Act of recalling in context
that's the amazing that's that's the
amazing truth so if you get to practice
either with yourself talking to yourself
or with other human beings even better
then you're gonna you're gonna be you're
kind of gonna become extremely good at
recalling I promise you that
so
um
hi Luke I'm learning two languages and
find it difficult to keep up Miguel says
I feel like I don't have time to speak
writing consume content for both
languages any tip well my tip is to step
back learn one language to fluency to be
too and then learn the other one that's
what I would do because if you're
tackling too much if you're like you
find it difficult to keep up it means
that you're losing Steam and you don't
want to lose steam so you can like in
the put one in the back burner this
doesn't mean you're gonna abandon it
maybe for two months you're gonna pursue
just one language you get good at it or
get better at it and then you come back
and and uh and you know learn the other
language or you scale down and maybe you
spend 10 minutes 15 minutes on one
language 15 minutes on the other
language you're going to learn more
slowly but it's a matter of compromise
you have to make choices in love in in
life
uh detail I think d y d i y Tau ever try
finish never tried fascinating language
one day why not
[Music]
Muhammad very interesting question did
it happen to you to feel frustrated when
you don't understand natives yes that's
one of the things I talk in
um in one of the videos that I made
about the book is that when I was 12 I
was crying I was watching a a a movie
and I was crying because I didn't
understand so that was the biggest
frustration to spawn this language
monster I told myself it's not like
there must be a way to understand this
and then so the answer is yes and I
still to this day sometimes
um this happened recently I was you know
I think I'm getting better and better
with Greek but I was listening to the
news that we're talking about the full
chat so we're talking about the
wildfires happening recent unfortunately
and I told myself I didn't understand
like at certain parts are a little bit
too technical or they talk about
politics I don't understand and I get
frustrated and I tell myself how is it
that now I understand almost everything
with these easy easy sorry easy polish
because I've been following easy Greek
videos in the podcast and everything and
then I get lost when I watch the news or
maybe when I watch a movie and that's
totally normal so frustration and
struggle and insecurities and doubts
they're part of
they're proud of the path and I talk
about this in the book biggest
frustrations I think the biggest
victories come from also the biggest
frustrations at least in my case
so uh let's see here I'm sorry if I'm
skipping some questions but
unfortunately I wish I could answer but
that would require the whole day thank
you so much for all the amazing
questions you're asking I I love every
single question
um Nadia says boosting my vocabulary is
one of my biggest issues I think a lot
of people focus too much on vocabulary
and how should I improve my vocabulary
the focus should be on having fun and
consuming content that you like for a
long period of time vocabulary will come
as a consequence of that I think the
biggest problem a lot of Learners have
is that they focus too much on the wrong
things like I have to learn all these
words no you have to yes of course you
have to learn these words but you don't
have to worry about learning words if
you're doing the right things if you're
exposing yourself to the right content
if you're listening to stuff you like if
you watch movies or you watch videos on
YouTube that you like and you're paying
attention maybe you're scribbling down
stuff you will start remembering you
have to remember this your brain is
never the same so the more you expose
yourself to the language the bigger the
infra the mental infrastructure your
intellectual linguistic infrastructure
is going to get in your brain and the
more nuts and points of reference it has
I see it as a spider web getting bigger
and bigger and these flies that are
words right like
these flies going around they get stuck
in the net so the more exposure you um
you you get the better you will become
remembering words something that doesn't
stick at the beginning will stick much
more easily and even on the fly without
you having to do any deliberate effort
because of this of of this
infrastructure that is slowly building
in your in your brain but the main focus
should not be I have to have to build my
vocabulary kids don't learn like that
they don't think about words when they
have to learn every day just learning by
using the language in a meaningful way
interacting in a meaningful way and
getting exposed to a lot of it
so another question about Arabic yes I'd
like I'd love to learn MSA and I'd love
to learn maybe Egyptian Egyptian Arabic
let's see but for now my choice now is
you know I'd love to learn Turkish in
January Hebrew and then maybe Arabic
there's too many languages to learn
anyway
have you ever been interested in career
in the career of translation either yes
I was at this in in Paris I I wanted to
pursue a career as a conference
interpreter rather than translator but
that didn't cut it and I ended up doing
something different and I'm very happy
that I did not I did not work as a as a
conference interpreter not because it's
not an amazing job it is but it's a
little bit stressful and I prefer being
an entrepreneur
helping you guys and training you guys
to learn languages better and more
efficiently
so
um
Anonymous user oh you were that was an
interesting question but now again the
chat disappeared uh let me see okay hi
look I've always been curious how do you
decide that you know a language well
enough to consider it learned I
emphasize the quotation marks and allow
yourself to begin learning a new one
very interesting question and it's a
very good question for polygons I would
say these the simple answers I consider
if you've considered the cefr central
European framework for languages this is
a European framework I would say B2 is a
level where your language course formed
and you move from learning the language
or trying to study language to using the
language and it's going to be very
difficult for you to forget it if you
don't reach that point there's a high
risk that your language core is going to
shrink and you're going to forget that
language especially if you reach maybe
A2 and then you'll stop learning it well
then you're you're completely gonna
forget it so uh that's that's my point
of reference and you never stop learning
a language but I consider that threshold
when you have reached the level when you
have reached those skills that then you
I consider that that language is
um has become part of my repertoire of
languages that I can use in a meaningful
way
uh let me see here uh
[Music]
uh your view on AI to help language
Learners I talked about that before I
think it's it's an amazing tool it's a
it's a an additional it's an add-on an
additional tool that you can use in
order to facilitate the acquisition of
language learning I believe that we use
you know we're talking about chat GPT
but AI in a way it's been around for a
long time like in a way deep l or Google
translate this is artificial
intelligence and I use Google Translate
extensively especially deep L now even
deep L right in order to create content
that is comprehensible for me that's
what really makes a difference you know
and now you have mac whisper uh in order
to you know you can listen to anything
and this thing creates a transcript even
for videos or podcasts that you for
which you don't have any subtitles or
it's amazing this is what really counts
for me is like AI is helping us creating
comprehensible content
um and Chachi BD is another Tool uh that
you can use that you can add to your
toolbox to learn even better but again
the core is always the same and it's
always listening or reading reading and
listening to interesting stuff if AI is
conducive to creating interesting
comprehensible Rich content
and fantastic
so let me go down where we have we have
here a 10 15 minutes to go
um what do you think of Duolingo is it
worth it is I I've I've I've been asked
this question all the time like when I
go to these language meetings hey how do
you start this language oh I've been
using Duolingo so that's a very common
thing I've never used Duolingo I think
it's not a very let's say acquisition
Rich tool but again I don't know it so I
don't want to talk about stuff I don't
know I think the Merit is in helping
people get started they do something
every day but that should be at the at
the very end of your language learning
session so just to give an example if
you have 30 minutes or maybe 45 minutes
to spend on say Dutch or Mandarin
Chinese you should spend 40 40 minutes
reading and listening again this is a
central point to stuff that you can
understand that is nice that it has
context maybe a real dialogue of two
interesting characters talking about
something interesting then if you have
five minutes
then you can spend five minutes playing
with Duolingo but if you just use
Duolingo because you have 20 minutes a
day and you think oh I'm smart I'm doing
Duolingo I'm sitting in I don't know
you're sitting in the bathroom you're
doing Duolingo for five minutes it ain't
gonna cut it it's not gonna work you
need to listen to authentic content for
a long period of time and
if you if you wanna if you want to use
Duolingo that then great but I would not
use it because the time is limited and
you want to spend it in a wise way so to
speak
so
um let's see here
[Music]
um
let me see if you have any other
interesting questions actually you do
uh some people say that AI will replace
translators interpreters what is your
opinion on that the career will no
longer exist I think that there's a need
for human contact anyway so I think it's
gonna it's gonna be around I don't know
for how long but it's possible that
translators might I think the
translation
machines might get very good but
translating is interpreting and I don't
know when it is going to happen the
machines are going to be able to
interpret a message translating is not
you know apparently is is a is just a
mechanical thing but it's not at all
it's it's it's the art of interpreting
messages and conveying you know one
message from one language to the other
um
uh
there's a famous linguist Italian
linguist who talked about that
say almost the same thing
who wrote an entire book about the
beauty of translation and why
uh while translating as an art the art
of interpreting messages and
transferring one message from one
culture to the other
um someone said Duolingo worked for me
just that it shouldn't be the only
application you use to learn language
that's correct uh Larry if you if you
like using Duolingo and it helps you
learn the language every day that's
fantastic you know but it shouldn't be
the only one it should be one of the
tools that you use where the the most
important activities are not playing
with an app but they're you know these
active the activities that I told you
about before and I've been insisting on
that for the entire hour here
so
um
let me see why are you learning Serbian
and is it hard for you I recently met a
girl from Croatia who was I wouldn't go
so far since she was angry but she asked
me why are you learning Serbian she was
quite surprised and I said well because
of the history of the Balkans when I was
a little kid I I still remember I was
reading the news the you know La
Republica this entire newspaper and I
was
um horrified by the war but also
fascinated as fascinating as I was
horrified at this history of the Balkans
and let's not talk about geopolitics
here but the serbs have always been
portrayed as the bad people you know and
when I was in Serbia and when I was in
Croatia I found the atmosphere quite
different I um I love you know both uh
croats and serbs but in general I've I
connected more with with serbs than
croats than Croatian people
so uh that's why I decided to learn
Serbian because they find it fascinating
if I'm a fascinating culture there I
connect with them I had a great time
when I was in Belgrade and uh and then
that's why I wanted to learn a language
from the Balkans also to understand the
culture to understand I have a lot of
books out history especially about the
the Balkan Wars and um
and now I have the capacity of
interacting and speaking these with
serbs and I'm excited to go to Serbia
I'm excited about going to sorting about
the idea of going to sermon
so uh uh have you tried the assemble the
digital assimil version no I'm a someone
called me Don papel which means uh you
know paper paper guy I love paper so
I've never used that
but if you like it you wanna if if you
wanna
if you want to use it then by all means
um go for it Tom asks no not Tom
Francisco de Leon asks I think that's a
title by Umberto Echo that's the title
of this book so
um
let me see here
how do you choose books appropriate
language level that's a fantastic
question
um so again we have seven minutes seven
eight minutes uh let me and let me
answer two or three other questions
um so first Daniel have you ever
considered learning check I have I might
learn check in the future going back to
the previous question
um which is uh let me see here about the
books um
yes normally what I do is I try to learn
I try to go through as many podcasts and
many videos as possible to to get to a
point where I can comfortably read a
book
um but you know reading a novel or not
even non-fiction is tough you have to
reach at the very least to be two levels
sometimes it's not even uh it's not even
sufficient so
um my technique is very simple open a
book read a page and look at how many
words you you do not know and and check
um if you can actually understand at the
very least the gist of it if you if you
don't that means that that book is is
not at your level and you should should
scale back if on the other hand you
understand maybe you missed some parts
but you understand the gist of it maybe
let's say 75 percent you can go through
it it's going to be a little bit painful
but uh you can give it a try so uh I
couldn't make it actually it's a it's an
excellent question for an entire video
thank thank you for that I'll I'll jot
it down a little bit later and I'll
think about how to answer it more
thoroughly
um I think we're about to finish guys I
can see there's a lot of interesting
questions here they're piling up
remember that you can either ask them
the next time I'll try to make these
Live Events if you find them useful a
little bit more often
uh I normally the Live Events we're
doing we're doing that of the academy
we're having a blast every every month
and we we meet and we have these
discussions about language learning and
about mindset and they're very useful uh
and I really like them but you know the
the reason why I haven't made these live
um you know events uh that often is just
because running now a a company and a
school is a little bit taxing so you
have a lot of things uh to to tackle but
I I love I love these Live Events they
give me a lot of energy and thank you
for all the amazing questions that give
me a lot of ideas about some other
YouTube videos
anyway
um
is there any app that you recommend for
taking notes effectively
um
I would say I would use remarkable if
you know or heard about remarkable or
just use notebooks I use notebooks and
all paper and Pen I think it's really
powerful uh that's the to me that's
still the best way the best technology
we have in order to remember words if
you if your aim is you know remembering
words or practicing is just to jot
things down on a piece of paper for
example I've been experimenting with
listening to a podcast and um every 10
seconds writing two or three keywords
and that makes me super attentive like I
pay attention like crazy my level of
attention is amazing and also I remember
words much better this is a technique
well I I mean I don't have time now to
explain technique but it's one of the
best techniques that I've I've uh I've
created in order to uh improve my
listening comprehension uh you know
improve my attention concentration and
vocabulary
um so
um
Islam says how do we learn an accent
perfectly well
it's a lot to say about there's a lot to
unpack uh you know when it comes to that
question anyway so guys I I think we're
about to finish I just want to tell you
again here
um I just want to tell you that I'm
first I'm really happy that a lot of you
showed up very
um it's always lovely to connect with
you
and again
um
this is the book in case you're
interested for over the next two days
we're gonna we're selling it at half
price it's not just a book it's the
audiobook that I recorded and
um and then there's an entire series of
questions uh of interviews behind the
scenes I share you know you see me
normally here on YouTube like this guy
speaks a bunch of languages maybe you
think I'm super confident and everything
and I think I am but
you know I share in the book I share a
lot of personal stories there's a lot of
struggles I shared a lot of insecurities
and I think uh the central idea of the
book is that anybody can learn a
language one two three four any language
actually
um and that at the end of the day I'm
not the superhero Super Genius really
just when I say it I really believe in I
was a disastrous school learning English
in French you should have seen me like
oh is that Luca this guy who speaks a
bunch of languages I was just a disaster
and I believe that what really changed
is my mindset I started to believe I
think that when you start believing uh
you start doing you start improving we
are limited by all our own limiting
beliefs that beliefs are learned think
about that you have learned like the
limits that you entertain in your mind
when it comes to language learning but
when it comes to anything there are
limits that Society has imposed upon you
like if you learn to question this stuff
and you start taking
um a stand and start taking a stance and
like reflective like you think about
okay well
I'm insecure why why is why is this
happening I'm hesitant when I speak I
don't remember words I'm not good at
grammar think think about I'll leave
this as a task for the next time we talk
think like start to be aware of how you
write how you express yourself when it
comes to language learning and when you
talk to yourself or talk to others about
your own experience as a language
learner right like when you find
yourself saying find yourself saying I
don't have the time or I'm not good at
grammar or oh you have to live in
country you have to get yourself a
boyfriend or a girlfriend to speak the
language fluently or you have to learn
grammar from the get-go or Jesus
everybody's going to think I'm a fool
when I speak so think about that because
these are limiting beliefs these are
this is what's really stopping you from
learning a language floor it's not
Grammar it's not words it's not you know
the complexity of a language you can
learn any language you've done that
yourself you've learned your own mother
tongue if you learn your own mother
tongue it's just because you went to the
process in a natural way you can
replicate that in a second language but
one of the most important components is
your mindset your approach towards
language learning towards other people
and most of all towards yourself this is
a Decor the message other core
um that's the reason why I'm I'm proud
that I got this book out it's it's full
of techniques yes of course you can
learn the you know some of the things I
talked about now briefly is we only
scratched the surface unfortunately due
to a lack of time
but most of all I share my path the the
mindset the transformation that happened
and uh I think that's that's worth
sharing
anyway that's it for now uh you're gonna
find just in case someone missed this or
is going to miss this you you will find
the recording on YouTube you can also
see the chat you know in the the live
section
when you watch it later got the whole
package thank you so much for all the
interesting questions I see here other
very interesting questions that I will
note uh I'll jot down and I will answer
either in the next live session or in
the form of some brand new YouTube
videos and there's more coming
thank you so much as always thank you
for watching and as always happy
language learning and bye from me from
Krakow
bye bye ciao